[Música]
buenos días a todos nací en un pequeño
pueblo de la sierra de huaral mi familia
pertenecía a la población de extrema
pobreza yo era la penúltima de 13
hermanos siete de ellos murieron antes
de cumplir cinco años incluida la última
entonces yo pasé a ser la más pequeña de
la casa mi madre golpeada por este dolor
me cuidaba mucho no iba a permitir que
yo me muera
en las fiestas patronales de mi pueblo
se incluía una corrida de toros y mi
madre decía que las personas que tomaban
la sangre de toro eran fuertes y
valientes
entonces cada corrida de toros mi madre
me daba una taza de sangre de toro aún
calientita era medio saladita
en verdad no sé si soy más valiente pero
si fui más fuerte mi madre dentro de su
conocimiento empírico y quizás sin
saberlo me estaba cuidando de
probablemente tener una anemia severa y
hoy estoy aquí precisamente para
hablarles de eso de la anemia
la anemia es un problema grave de salud
pública que afecta casi al 50 por ciento
de nuestro país por ejemplo en los niños
menores de 3 años afecta a más del 43% y
en mujeres gestantes a más del 28% y lo
que es más triste es que arrastramos
este problema por décadas
pero qué es la niña porque tenemos que
actuar sobre este problema de salud
pública porque afecta el desarrollo de
las personas de las familias y por tanto
señores el desarrollo de nuestro país
les explico mejor
cuando tenemos anemia nuestro organismo
tiene menos oxígeno del que necesita
para funcionar óptimamente esto se
refleja en los niveles de hemoglobina en
sangre que tenemos
la hemoglobina es la que se encarga de
transportar el oxígeno desde los
pulmones a todo nuestro cuerpo es algo
así
como el carrito que recorre todo nuestro
organismo a través de las venas y
arterias que serían las pistas dejando
su carga el oxígeno en nuestras células
y tejidos esto es grave porque si
nuestras células no tienen el oxígeno
suficiente no van a funcionar al 100%
por lo tanto nuestras capacidades
físicas cognitivas e inmunológicas están
disminuidas
es algo así como si en lima hubiera una
huelga de carros la hemoglobina y las
personas el oxígeno no tuvieran cómo
llegar a su centro de trabajo nuestras
células y tejidos cómo funcionarían las
empresas si no llega toda su fuerza
laboral
en el mejor de los casos a medias y
quizás muchas empresas dejarían de
funcionar
y cuáles son los efectos de que las
células y tejidos dejen de funcionar o
no tengan el oxígeno suficiente por
ejemplo en los menos en los niños
menores de 5 años se interrumpe el
desarrollo cerebral al no tener oxígeno
las neuronas no alcanzan su potencial de
desarrollo
y en los adultos significa tener una
pérdida de la productividad cansancio
menos energía para hacer las cosas del
día a día como tienes menos oxígeno tu
cuerpo funciona con sus capacidades
limitadas
el estudio impacto económico de la
anemia en el país revela que la anemia
le cuesta al país el 0.62 por ciento del
pbi mientras que un programa de
prevención efectivo en niños y mujeres
alcanzaría un presupuesto menor al 0.01
por ciento del pbi es decir
menos de lo que le cuesta a nuestro país
tener los índices de anemia que tenemos
el estado viene ejecutando políticas
públicas para erradicar la anemia una de
las principales estrategias es el
reparto de multimillonaria es entre el
2015 y 2016 se han utilizado casi 35
millones de soles sin embargo las cifras
de la anemia no han disminuido por el
contrario en el último año incluso ha
aumentado
a pesar de todos los esfuerzos y
seguramente muy buenas intenciones no se
están logrando los resultados esperados
consideramos que algo no está
funcionando bien la estrategia tiene que
replantearse llevo más de 20 años
trabajando en relación a la anemia y en
este tiempo he concluido en una
hipótesis de los factores que podrían
estar determinando que no se logren los
resultados esperados 1 el tipo de hierro
que utilizamos para combatir la anemia y
2 la educación que se hace respecto de
la anemia les explico a qué me refiero
empecé a trabajar
en la anemia en 1992 cuando por cosas de
la vida llegué a hachís a un rincón de
la selva peruana cuya población vivía en
medio del narcotráfico y el terrorismo
muy golpeada por la anemia y la
desnutrición que eran casi generalizadas
por mi formación académica conocía de
los problemas nutricionales pero ahora
estaba en la cancha estaba y mirando a
los niños con el cabello rubio
despigmentante pálidos y cansados
entonces esa información que antes eran
cifras estadísticas ahora eran gente de
carne y hueso pero por qué es importante
utilizar el hierro en mí ni con el
hierro mi nico al ser un hierro de
fuente animal es compatible con el
hierro que tenemos nosotros en nuestra
sangre su nivel de absorción está por
encima del 20 por ciento
no hay que tener cuidado con los
facilitadores e inhibidores de la
absorción y porque por una razón
fundamental la molécula del hierro está
adosada a una molécula de proteína y eso
hace la diferencia en el mecanismo de
absorción con los hierros no en mínimos
entonces
si tenemos dos tipos de hierro uno el
hierro noemí niko que tiene un bajo
nivel de absorción que produce
estreñimiento y hay que tener cuidado
con los facilitadores e inhibidores de
la absorción y por otro lado tenemos el
hierro en mini co
que se absorbe por encima del 20% y no
hay que tener cuidado con los
facilitadores e inhibidores de la
absorción por qué no utilizamos hierro
emín y ccoo en nuestra lucha contra la
anemia
he tenido esta pregunta en mi cabeza por
mucho tiempo
cuando regrese
o quizá desde chile junto a mi amiga el
bailar
decidimos implementar las galletas
fortificadas y decidimos hacerlas como
lo harían los pobladores cuando nosotras
ya no estemos
sin embargo
no contábamos con que las galletas se
iban a poner rancias en 20 días fue muy
triste tuvimos que recoger las galletas
de las 40 comunidades que ya habíamos
repartido
como el gemini que viene de la sangre de
la vaca tiene un color y olor
característico que no es fácil de
disimular en una de esas tantas pruebas
que hacíamos mezclamos la no globina con
el cacao en polvo y descubrimos que el
olor a sangre desaparecía totalmente o
maravilla
teníamos el vehículo perfecto para
desarrollar una alternativa en base a
hierro en mímica y es así que nace
nuestra cocoa fortificada con hierro y
mímica para ser agregado a la taza de
leche las venas
los jugos etc
nosotros elaboramos
nosotros elaboramos en el centro de
salud cuchilla y un día llegó una señora
gestante en días de dar a luz tenía el
diagnóstico de placenta previa sin
embargo por razones religiosas
no pudimos hacerle la transfusión
sanguínea que requería y el doctor me
indicó que le diera la cocoa fortificada
para sentir que algo hacíamos por esta
señora que ya se estaba muriendo mi
sorpresa fue que al mes y medio y que la
señora había seguido tomando la cocoa la
vi caminando en la plaza de armas
claro seguía con anemia porque estaba
pálida pero había pasado el momento
crítico en que estaba con esta
experiencia en 1996 junto a project hope
y usaid ejecutamos un proyecto en la
región en el departamento de san martín
con la asistencia técnica de la
universidad peruana cayetano heredia
donde realizamos los estudios con
rigurosidad científica
tuvimos muy buenos resultados los
estudios evidencian una rápida
recuperación de la hemoglobina en la
sangre
estábamos felices con los resultados
pensábamos que debíamos estar en todos
los programas sociales pero aún no lo
hemos logrado
entonces decidimos hacer empresa
meternos por la parte comercial y
logramos ingresar a una de las cadenas
más grandes del país primero con la
cocoa fortificada pero como la idea
inicial era cómo llegar a los más
pequeños pensamos qué cosa podría hacer
más rica que una golosina entonces
decidimos hacer unos chocolatitos que
podrán probar ahora a la salida de la
charla
son chocolatitos pequeños de 10 gramos
fortificados con hierro y mini co por
tanto se absorberá muy bien en el
organismo de quienes la consumen
trabajamos dos años en el desarrollo de
estos chocolatitos con el aporte del
programa innova-te perú del ministerio
de la producción el chocolate ha sido
muy bien recibido por los usuarios a que
el niño no le gusta un chocolate
salió al mercado en el 2015
y desde entonces hasta hoy la demanda se
ha quintuplicado nos volvemos locos con
la producción
estoy muy orgullosa por lo avanzado sin
embargo reconozco que mi sueño de llegar
con el jeremy nico a los más pobres
donde la anemia golpea de manera letal
aún no se ha cumplido y por favor no me
malentiendan no quiero decir que compren
mi producto mis chocolates no son la
única solución lo que quiero decirles y
resaltar es que existe una alternativa
eficaz para prevenir o combatir la
anemia es el hierro en méjico
entonces usemos jeremy nico en sus
diferentes formas si en alimentos
fortificados pero también en carne
pescado hígado sangre cita
el uso de este tipo de hierro puede en
corto tiempo ayudarnos a disminuir la
anemia especialmente en las familias de
extrema pobreza como era mi familia
combatir la anemia es combatir la
pobreza es combatir las desigualdades y
es también una forma de inclusión social
y económica
entonces debemos combatirla con las
armas más eficaces y el hierro mínimo
constituye una muy buena alternativa sin
embargo para que esta estrategia eficaz
tenga sostenibilidad en el tiempo es
necesario acompañarla de manera
inseparable de una estrategia educativa
nutricional sobre la anemia
que trascienda las órdenes o
prescripciones médicas
porque combatir la anemia
pasa por cambiar hábitos alimenticios al
interior del hogar para eso se requiere
analizar las conductas actuales
y comprender por qué es imprescindible
cambiarlas
y aquí tengo que decir que los
profesionales de la salud no somos
formados para educar porque el problema
de la niña socialmente no es comprendida
como una enfermedad grave como el cáncer
por ejemplo entonces si las personas no
lo consideran grave entonces tampoco
considerarán que hay algo importante que
hacer al respecto
las familias tienen que entender y
descubrir la magnitud de lo que
significa tener anemia como la anemia
mata sus sueños de desarrollo
de tener éxito familiar pensando en eso
hemos desarrollado el módulo educativo
podemos prevenir la anemia basado en la
pedagogía constructivista en el cual
compartimos estos conceptos en espacios
pequeños de no más de 30 personas y un
tiempo promedio de 30 minutos
los asistentes a estas sesiones
educativas analizan y reflexionan sobre
la función de la hemoglobina en nuestro
cuerpo
de como los hábitos no saludables
afectan a los más pequeños de la casa y
comprenden entonces el beneficio de
ingresar a la dieta diaria alimentos
ricos en hierro y mímica como la carne
el pescado las vísceras la sangrecita
etc
asimismo se cuestionan costumbres como a
quien atendemos primero a la hora de
comer y aquí le damos la carne más
grande
es decir hacemos que los asistentes
dejan de percibirse como beneficiarios
de un programa y se conviertan en los
protagonistas de su cambio de su
desarrollo de su éxito familiar porque
porque la decisión de combatir contra la
anemia está en sus manos en sus
decisiones en la capacidad de asumir el
liderazgo de su éxito familiar lo que
les he querido decir a lo largo de esta
charla es que si utilizamos el hierro y
mímica
y desarrollamos una estrategia adecuada
de educación que trascienda las órdenes
médicas con seguridad podemos combatir
la anemia en corto tiempo podemos
ganarle la guerra a esta enfermedad que
nos ha estado robando nuestras
capacidades el desarrollo de las
personas
de las familias que nos ha estado
robando el desarrollo de nuestro país
si lo decidimos
seguro que lo lograremos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]